why do you think um
why do you think so many people
are trying to you know
silence you from having people
uh hear what you have to say there's got
to be a reason for somebody to say
listen this guy's doing more harm than
good what do you say to those people
so we're this and it partially relates
to mass formation this theory of
matthias desmond not my theory and
it it partially relates it goes back to
a very active campaign to promote two
people for the nobel prize
if if you track back to the origin of a
lot of these attacks yeah it goes back
to the very concerted effort that was
mounted by
bioentech pfizer
and uh by u-pin
to promote kuriko and weissman for the
nobel prize and they got most of the
major prizes they got the lasker award
which by the way is managed by an
investment fund
um but they didn't get the no bell and
um it was fascinating watching this play
out
it was a standard concerted campaign and
there is a school of thought that if one
wishes to win the nobel prize you have
to use mass media in order to influence
the committee
and so i saw this playing out
particularly my wife did which is what
kind of sparked all of this off
is i was being written out of history in
in wikipedia and in every other platform
and people were it's basically a stolen
valor situation
people were taking credit for what i did
in the late 1980s i've never denied what
they did i've never attacked what they
did
it is it's a scientific effort that they
why why would they do that because kai
can you do me a favor can you pull up
the article i gave you
uh
from uh
uh uh
i give you an article uh in regards to
who came out with mrna if you can pull
that article up it's not that one it's
one of the most recent ones i just sent
you
this is you talking about the nature one
uh
that one right there okay so this
article came up because the biggest
thing is when i go online and i see
where people give you a lot of criticism
is he has on his linkedin profile that
he's the inventor of mrna right that's
what they said so let me kind of put
this on and see what you're going to be
saying so i go online and uh there's
this doctor called dr
eric topple if i'm pronouncing his last
name correctly or not and he's followed
by some credible people it's not like
he's not followed by credible he is he
is part of the mainstream narrative has
been for a long time fair enough he said
on a related matter dr malone who
asserts he is the inventor of mrna
vaccine
and actively cultivates vaccine
skepticism is not and has admitted
that fact and then he puts the links
below and talking about two other people
and then he brings up this picture
of you and his tweet but if you read
this article go all the way to the top
and the article that says go all the way
to the top all the way to the top how
scientists drew wiseman med 87 grs-87
and catalin kariko developed the
revolutionary mrna technology inside
covet vaccine while i'm reading through
this article there's not a single
mention of your name in here
and then in the comments section some
people say
why if you can do ctrl f type in malone
do control f and type in malone the only
place you see this is in the bottom by
john carter whoever commented this on
january 2022 which is three days ago
this article is complete rewrite of
history no mention of dr malone who
claims to have discovered in vitro and
in vivo rna transit of affection at the
salk institute in 1987 and that he later
invented mrna vaccines in 1988 this
pre-dates anything cited here so
you your claim is i'm the inventor of
this
they say you are not they don't mention
any of the names
why are they saying that and why are you
saying that you're the inventor
so the reason that i'm saying it is
because i have nine issued patents that
have my name on it that were filed in
1988 okay okay
um and this is public information it's
widely available and never cited
so for instance the uh nature article of
the tangled history of mrna vaccines
which i was uh i had i provided that
author with extensive access to deep
information okay including the primary
uh invention disclosure which i
validated by um allowing him to speak
enabling him to speak to the scientist
mark kindy the cross signed it i think
it was 1987 or 1988. you said enabling
him who is him
i'm speaking of the author of the
article okay
um in the um tangled history of mrna
that was published in nature
um that none of these articles
have cited the patents
that have been
part of this mainstream press narrative
all the way through including
so this traces back to the
let me let me roll back a little bit
more
drew weissman is a tony fauci postdoc
katie currico is literally a former
hungarian spy
can you type that can you type that up
there just type in her name yeah and
type in hungarian spy because i want us
to
uh just go back to the article prior to
that go all the way to the top yeah it's
in the european press my goal is by the
end of the call by the end of the
interview just type in her uh copy paste
her name yeah but i i recommend you
don't use don't use google
and then go do copy paste what would you
like us to use
okay go to duckduckgo and
uh type in her name and hungarian spy
hungarian spice just so you know nothing
pops up so far
okay
a typical hungarian story when i was
only getting a spectrum cover 19
kilometers a little bit
there's no more names on the pfizer
there we go click second click euro news
second one
that's third one i was innocent this is
this is soviet era ghost returns to hong
kong 19 vaccine scientists
hiroshiga has just got her job as jones
and hungary in 1978 the secret police
knocked on her door kierko was given a
choice agreed to cooperate with the
communist state security apparatus or
accept that her career in scientific
research was over before it had begun i
knew how the system worked i was afraid
so i signed the recruitment document she
signed she said so this is her response
there's multiple other publications that
go back and i was contacted by people
from hungary early on in this and said
look this is what we know about her
who has verified that she was a
hungarian spy that's a credible multiple
articles do you know any one of them
that you can like no okay you can easily
search and find okay so fair enough but
go ahead you're saying so she's a
hungarian so these two have um an
interesting history background
katie i learned about katie she
contacted me
um it was almost a decade after i had
done the original work i was working at
uc davis as a assistant professor okay
and you can find this the the footprints
of this interaction in her first mrna
related paper
in which she not only cites my work as
as one of the standard academic
citations
but she lists in the acknowledgements
um appreciation for my interaction with
her
she called me i put her in touch with um
junior people in my laboratory group
another assistant professor i put her in
touch with a professor at uc
riverside who had done key work in mrna
five prime and three prime and
translated region act uh interactions
and uh did anything i could to help her
invited her to a conference in annapolis
that i had set up
that i was organizing
and and actively tried to help her move
forward with her work
this is all
literally just about a decade after i
did my work
so she is very aware of what i had done
i helped her early on
and then when she and drew weissman
wrote their
um
initial review paper where they talked
about mrna and mrna vaccines which is
what this whole thread builds off of
they grossly minimized my contributions
why would they do that and how could
they do that that's this is the way
science is science is a wicked
competitive business
and it's easy to do you just it's you
under sight or you miss sight or you
fail to cite so so let me ask you let me
ask you this for me my experience have
been for whatever reason doctors are
extremely arrogant
and very cocky almost like a god uh
what's the word i'm looking for
the hubris might be a word hubris might
be the word but more like
the
feeling of i'm god i know what i'm
talking about i'm the expert it's it's
insanely competitive it's all about
money and power so so but here's the
point though when i do a lot of the
research when people come i'm not in
your world so all i'm doing is i'm just
speculating stuff and i'm trying to get
a little bit closer to
uh the truth by uh
asking people on both sides so
you know most people will say nobody
ever invented a vaccine it's co-inventor
you did it with the group there was a
group of people that is the criticism so
let me let me give you some feedback
here's a metaphor okay just because a
group of engineers designed the 737 max
it doesn't mean that the wright brothers
didn't invent power flight
the core technology
and the applications
are disclosed in
nine issued u.s patents and multiple
foreign patents that were filed in i
think it was march 1988 and another
patent that was filed by the salk
institute but dropped and it was filed
on exactly the same day
so there this whole issue this is why i
you know and it's
frankly it's my wife that is
really really pissed off about all of
this about this stolen valor is because
she lived through it it was an
incredibly stressful period in our time
i don't understand how that's possible
though doc because
you know steve jobs can talk about he
invented the you know the technology
everybody in the world knows it's
wozniak you know
nobody can take that credit away from
moz and washington that was in 1977
seventy so so there has been a concerted
campaign
to write me out of history all the way
through
why though because the nobel so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]